oh hi everyone thank you all for coming
today I'm going to be talking about how
you can run Microsoft sequel server in
compute engine in a highly available
manner and by the end of this session I
want you to know what that looks like
the issues you might run into and where
you can go to get more information on
setting this up I won't be talking about
the cloud sequel announcement from
yesterday by D little bit broad bit
blindsided by it to be honest so first I
want to talk about myself for a little
bit my name is Tom I'm a reliability
engineer at Rackspace I'd be in a
Rackspace for about five and a half
years and I've been working with Google
cloud for the past 18 months my
background is as a window space ad which
I did for over ten years and which is
why about eighteen months ago I was
asked to join our managed Google team as
the first windows expert globally now my
first task in that role was to figure
out just how we could support windows in
GCP and my second task was to figure out
how we can do highly available sequel so
a lot of what you're going to see here
is based on my first few months in that
role as well as some learnings that
we've taken from customers along the way
so you may have noticed a picture have
rather few flags in there and that's
because that Rackspace likes rewarding
rancors with flags each of those
represents a different certification
that I managed to achieve and I actually
have all of the GTP sets including the
network and security ones I have a
couple of micro Spurs as well so I think
that makes me pretty well placed to talk
about this subject
finally you may have noticed my accent
I'm not from around here I'm from a
little island called Britain that you
may have heard of there are a few things
going on there at the moment but
thankfully I get to distract myself by
watching the rugby
although please avoid any talk about the
sticks and they
because that's still a bit of a sore
point if you don't know where rugby is
it's a bit like American football except
there's a lot less padding and we throw
the ball backwards rather than forwards
now you didn't come here to listen to me
talk about myself all day so this is
what I'm going to be covering for the
rest of the session
I'm going to start off by looking at the
various options that are available in
sequel server and that won't just be
from a high availability perspective I'm
also going to cover things like disaster
recovery and retailing this will be
quite general it won't be GCP specific
the GCP specific stuff is going to be in
section 2 where I'll show you what a
highly available sequel architecture in
GCP actually looks like I'll also talk
through a few of the caveats a few of
the things that you need to watch out
for and then I'll move on to doing a
quick demo just so you can see what it
looks like in real life so let's start
by looking at what options are available
in sequel server and you can see it's
rather nice Venn diagram I have three
main areas on there there's high
availability if you want to be
protecting against individual instance
failures there's disaster recovery if
you want to be protecting against entire
region failures and there's also read
scaling if either your application has
quite high read requirements or you have
a geographically redundant app
geographically spread up that would
benefit from more data locality so for
high availability one of the options you
might consider is belt over clustering
it's a much older technology much more
widely known and especially if you
already have existing Sun infrastructure
it might be a good option for you at
least on-prem for disaster recovery you
might have thought about using sequel
mirroring although Microsoft are
deprecating that in favor of the basic
availability group which I'll be talking
about a bit later on log shaping is
probably a better option if you're just
doing disaster recovery it is a lot more
simple to
setup has very few requirements it's
essentially just a few sequel jobs that
run on node to backup databases and one
instance restore them on another that's
very easy can also do read scaling if
you really want to but I probably
wouldn't use log shipping for that if
you're trying to do transaction read
scaling log shipping isn't really a good
fit because your clients are going to be
constantly disconnected when those
restore operations are happening and
there's also going to be quite a bit of
latency between the backup and the
restore so for transactional rescaling
you're probably better off with
something like replication it's a bit
more complex to set up the log shipping
there's pretty good at doing read
scaling and then in the middle you have
always on always on can actually do all
three of these things it can do high
availability it can do disaster recovery
and it can do read scaling so if you
want one technology that can do all
three of these things always-on is a
really good option before moving on I
will point out the can actually mix and
match these as well so you could have a
failover cluster that uses log shipping
for disaster recovery if you wanted to
for the rest of the session though I'm
just going to focus on failover
clustering and always-on that's because
they're the high availability options so
let's thought by taking a look at
failover clustering as I said it's a
much older technology quite well
understood and it's the pretty simple
concept you have an IP address up there
that can float between all of the
instances in your cluster and that's
what your client will use to access the
instance you have multiple servers as
members of your cluster and then to
those servers you present some kind of
shared storage that shared storage is
typically a fan learn so you need some
existing fan infrastructure there it can
also be an SMB 3 file share if you're
using Windows Server 2016 or above but
if you're using a file share you need to
make sure that's highly available as
well and then you put your databases
both your databases and the system
databases on that shared storage
this is what it looks like in normal
operation you have the IP address on the
active instance you have the sequel
services running on only the active
instance they're stopped on all of the
passive instances you have that shared
storage mounted on the primary instance
and you have that primary instance
servicing the traffic when you initiate
it fell over the sequel service is the
first dot on the primary instance that
process can actually take a few seconds
to complete because sequel will wait for
any pending transactions to complete but
once the services have stopped the
shared storage will be dismounted from
the primary active instance the IP
address will be removed from that
instances Nick the storage will be
mounted onto your passive further and
then the IP address will be added to
your passive servers Nick finally the
services will be started up on the
passive server now the amount of time it
takes for sequel services to start up
can be quite variable it can also be
quite a long period of time when the
sequel services thought up they have to
read some database and table metadata
into memory and some transactions may
need to be replayed so you may find that
this whole process could take anything
from 30 seconds to complete if you have
relatively small databases up to a few
minutes if your database is a terabytes
in size and that's 30 seconds to a few
minutes that your clients are able to
access any of these databases so if el
tovar itself can be quite slow so if we
go over a few of the considerations for
a failover cluster you only require a
single copy of the databases because
they exist from that shared storage
there is a requirement for shared
storage as I said that will typically be
a Sandlin or an SMB 3 file share the
fell over can be relatively slow just
because of the process it has to go
through you can't spend eight centers
natively with this and what I mean by
that is
there's nothing in the sequel fell over
cluster that will allow you to span
datacenters you can actually achieve
this if your standard supports block
level replication or if you're using
Windows Server 2016 where you have
options for using block level
replication within that but with what
you get with a failover cluster this
isn't something you can actually do and
those passive servers are really just
fat they're doing nothing I kind of keep
Nita caviar out slightly so the passive
servers aren't able to service traffic
for an individual Farrell / cluster
instance that is only active on a single
node at a time but you can actually add
multiple failover cluster instances to
the same Windows cluster or they bear in
mind if you do that then you need some
kind of logic in your application to
know which instance to connect to for
the database you're trying to access so
now let's move on to always-on
specifically availability groups this
was introduced in sequel server 2012 the
standard availability groups are
currently only available in the
enterprise edition of sequel although in
the standard edition of sequel you can
use the basic availability group the
basic availability group is a lot like a
standard availability group it just has
a few key limitations such as only being
able to have a maximum of two servers as
a member of our availability group and
only being able to have a single
database within there as well
you also can use read scaling with the
basic availability group before going
into always-on in a bit more detail
first just want to cover off a couple of
terms just so we all know what they are
an availability group is the simplest
unit have failover within an always-on
cluster you add your databases to the
availability group and you fail over an
entire availability group which means
that all the databases within there will
be failed over at the same time you can
only add a database to a single
availability group at a time but a
single sequel instance can host multiple
of
ability groups at the same time and
availability group may also have zero or
more listeners the listener is the
access point that the client will use it
has a DNS name which is what the client
should use to connect and it also has
one or more dedicated IPS
a listener can only be associated with a
single availability group at a time and
through management studio you can only
assign a single listener to an
availability group as I said a an
availability group can have multiple
listeners but to do that you have to go
into fell over cluster manager add the
listeners there and then run some TC
equal whenever you perform a failover if
you go to the link on the screen or scan
the QR code it will take you to some
documentation that shows you how to set
those up you may be wondering why you
want multiple listeners and I'll talk
about that a bit later on this is what
always-on looks like you still have this
single listener that can float between
all of the servers in the cluster you
still have multiple servers in the
cluster but the key difference here is
that you don't have any shared storage
each of these firmers has its own set of
local storage on that local storage
you'll add your databases or you add
your databases to the availability group
and then those databases will be
replicated to the storage on all of the
instances within the cluster however
what isn't replicated or any of the
system databases so when you install a
sequel instance in an always-on cluster
were you actually just installed as a
normal sequel instance the same way you
would if you weren't using always-on it
does mean that you can use GC images to
build these by the way and then add them
to a cluster afterwards so because the
system databases are replicated that
means anything that you add to a system
database needs to be added to all of
these instances individually so sequel
logins sequel jobs they don't get
replicated you somehow have to manage
adding them to all of these instances
this is what always-on looks like in
service the listener is on the active
instance the service is this time or
running on all of the servers in the
cluster at the same time they're not
stopped on any of the passive ones and
you have the primary database in read
write mode you also have the secondary
database in read-only mode and then you
have the primary database replicating
over to the secondary database when you
initiate and fell over the primary
database is marked as read only the
direction of replication is flipped the
secondary database is marked as read
right and the listener is moved to the
secondary instance and that's it that's
a fairly complete I may think that looks
quite quick actually this is a really
quick process probably take you a few
seconds most of the time what's even
better is that is an actually
predictable amount of time there's a
configuration parameter you can set in
your availability group to say how long
this fell over should take to complete
now I did mention you can also use an
always-on availability group for
retailing and this is how you would do
it so for a normal client request to an
availability group the client will
connect to the listener the listener
will connect the client to the active
instance and then the active instance
will service the request if you want to
use read-only if you want to use read
scaling you need to take advantage of
read-only routing to do that you specify
this in your connection string
application intent equals read-only the
client will still connect to the
listener the listener will still connect
the client to the primary instance
however the difference here is that the
primary instance will see that this has
been specified in the connection string
and rather than servicing the request
itself it will consult its read-only
routing list that to determine which
instance should service the request now
the read-only routing list effectively
says that if this particular instance is
active then these instances are able to
service region
for it so you kids have a read-only
routing list that says whenever sequel
one is active then boasts equal to and
sequel three are able to service the
request and you could have a second
entry in there that phase that it's
equal to is active then only sequel one
is able to service that request
so once the active instance has
consulted it's read-only routing list it
will pick an instance for the clan to
connect to it will tell the client to
connect to that instance and then the
client or the secondary instance will
service the request so these are the
considerations that you have for
always-on generally each node has to
have a copy of the databases on it so
your storage requirements might be
increased by using this however there's
no requirement for shared storage so you
can actually get away with using cheaper
storage the failover is relatively fast
and can actually be predictable and you
can natively spanned eight centers with
this the underlying technology here is
essentially sequel mirroring and because
of that your sequel instances can
actually be anywhere they could be on
prayer could be another cloud provider
could be in another gtp region it
doesn't really matter you can put them
anywhere and finally those secondary
instances can get some use that can be
used as read replicas so what what would
I recommend you actually use in gtp and
this has kind of changed slightly given
the announcement yesterday so I say if
what you're looking for is highly
available sequel and you have very
standard requirement then actually the
manage pal sequel offering might be a
pretty compelling offer because it's a
pass option you won't have so much
management overhead the only problem is
you won't get as much flexibility so if
you wanted to do high availability and
still maintain the flexibility of
managing your own sequel instances you
really have the choice between failover
clustering and always-on the problem
with failover clustering is this
requirement for shared storage in gtp a
persistent disk can only be mounted to a
single instance at a time in
read write mode that means that you
can't really use shared storage in GCP
for a failed over cluster you could
create you could use the block level
replication options within Windows
Server 2016 to get around that but then
you're adding additional management
overhead an additional complexity to
this and really you might as well just
use always-on from the start because
it's designed for this type of scenario
the one thing you may be considering
there is the licensing cost because as I
said for a standard availability group
you have to use the Enterprise Edition
of sequel that means you're paying a
much larger licensing cost however you
may be able to get away with using the
basic availability group you may find
that the limitations don't really affect
you that much so now let's take a look
at what always-on actually looks like
within GCP so I'm going to build up here
is a diagram that shows you a single
region deployment of always-on after
building that diagram up I'll explain
what slight differences there would be
with the multi region deployment so
you'll start by picking a region that
region should have at least three zones
and then you'll pick three of those
things to use I've called them zone a
zone B and zone C you'll then create
three subnets one of those subnets
will be your shared services subnet that
will have instances deployed into it in
all three of these zones you'll then
have a second subnet which I've called
the sequel one subnet that will have a
single instance deployed into it and
that instance will be in zone a and then
you'll create your third subnet that
again will have a single instance
deployed into it and that instance will
be in zone C you'll then create two
domain controllers both in subnet one
with one of them in Zone A and one of
them in zones fee the reason we create
them in those zones is to avoid is to
minimize the
intros Oh in traffic between the sequel
instances and the domain controllers
although again giving Google announced
manage the ad yesterday that might be a
good option to use as well
you'll also create a file share witness
in Zone B the file share witness is
effectively just the file server and all
it's doing is providing quorum for the
cluster to avoid any thoughts or blip
brain scenarios
the reason we're deploying get into zone
B is because a Microsoft best practice
is to keep your file share witness in a
zone that doesn't have any sequel
services in it that's to avoid any sort
of network partitioning effects once
you've done that you'll create two
sequel instances one of those sequel
instances will be in subnet two the
other one will be in subnet 3 those
sequel instances will have their own set
of persistent disks they will also have
an alias IP range specified on them now
if you don't know what an alias IP
ranges it's effectively a subnet of the
subnet that the instance is deployed in
and it tells gtp there any requests for
IPs within that alias IP range should be
sent to that instance so it just means
you can add additional IP addresses to
that instant and gtp will know how to
read the requests you'll then create a
Windows cluster that windows cluster
will have the two sequel instances as
members it will also have the file share
witness as its quorum and it will have
some call cluster resources in there as
well
those cluster resources will have a DNS
name and they will also have two IP
addresses in this case that's because it
those call cluster resources will have
an IP address from each of the alias IP
ranges that are specified on the sequel
instance what this means is that that
resource can be hosted on either of
these instances well over cluster
manager will check to see if there is an
IP that is in the same subnet as the
primary IP of the instance you're
failing over - and if there is it will
bring that resource online you'll then
create some availability groups in this
case I've created
those availability groups will have some
databases within them
those availability groups can also be
filled over independently and the
availability groups will have their own
listeners again the listeners will have
a DNS name and they will have two IPS
one from each of the alias IP ranges on
the sequel instances so that's the
single region deployment of always-on
with the multi region deployment it
looks quite similar there are only a
couple of changes that you'd actually
make the first thing you would deploy
some domain controllers into that region
as well and create a shared services
subnet within that region that you
create at least two domain controllers
for redundancy
you'll also create additional sequel
instances in that region and with those
sequel instances you will create them
each in their own subnet and you will
specify an alias IP range on them you'll
then add additional IP to all of the
cluster resources from those alias IP
ranges you specified effectively your
cluster resources should have the same
number of IP addresses as you have
sequel instances within that cluster
finally the file share witness should
actually be moved to its own region
because if you have a multi region
deployment the best practice there is to
ensure its deploys into a region that
doesn't have any sequel services within
it again that's to avoid any sort of
network partitioning effects so one of
the things you're going to have to
choose when you create the availability
group is the availability mode you've
got two choices here synchronous and
asynchronous with the synchronous
availability mode transactions are only
committed on the primary database once
the secondary databases have confirmed
that the transactions have been
committed on them it's really good from
a data consistency perspective because
it means you can guarantee those the
secondaries are up to date with the
primary however from a write performance
perspective it's not quite very good
because your primary is having to wait
for your secondaries to commit
transactions you'll actually find that
your right performance is decreased so
you should only really use this when the
latency between the instances is
relatively low and data consistency is
your primary concern
asynchronous availability mode on the
other hand commits the transactions
immediately on the primary database and
then the primary database doesn't really
care what happens with the secondaries
it's really good from a write
performance perspective because there is
no impact on your write performance
however it's not quite so good from a
data consistency perspective because if
you try to fell over to one of these
instances there's a chance you might
lose data now the good news is this
isn't a choice that you have to make it
the availability group level you can
configure this on each of the instances
within the availability group so the way
that I would typically see this being
used is that you would have your primary
region and the instances that you deploy
into a primary region will use the
synchronous availability mode the reason
for this is that the latency between
those instances is going to be
relatively low tens of milliseconds
maybe and you're most likely to be
failing over between instances though
within the same region if you deploy
sequel instances to any other regions
you'll use the asynchronous availability
mode the reason for that is that you're
unlikely to be failing over to that
region unless there's a disaster and if
there's a disaster
you can probably afford some data loss
and the latency between the instances
and different regions is relatively high
you're looking at hundreds of
milliseconds as opposed to tens so if
you were to try and you think Rinna's
available availability across regions
you'll probably find that your write
performance is affected a bit too much
so client connectivity is the next thing
you might be thinking about especially
because these listeners might have
multiple IPs
so how exactly the clients connect to
those
instances well as I said the clients
could connect using the DNS name and in
the default configuration the fell over
cluster manager will register every
possible IP address within DNS if you
have an always-on away client you should
use this in your connection string multi
subnet failover equals true that will
tell the client to attend to connect to
all of those IP addresses at the same
time and as soon as one of the
connections is successful it will stop
trying to connect to the rest of them
this allows fell over to be as fast as
possible legacy clients unfortunately
are going to get back a list of IP
addresses they're going to pick one at
random to connect to and that happens to
be an IP address that isn't currently
online your clients going to get a
timeout so if you do have a legacy
client you should configure these two
parameters on the list in the cluster
resource the first is register all
providers IP which each is set to 0 that
tells the client that it should only
register the currently active IP address
in DNS you should also lower the host
rate called TTL by default that's set to
20 minutes and I don't know about you
but I don't want to be waiting 20
minutes for my client to fill over you
should probably reduce that to something
a lot more sensible maybe start 2
minutes and see if that's alright for
you if not lower it a bit more all they
do bear in mind that the lower the host
record TTL the more DNS traffic is going
to hit your domain controllers if you do
want to be able to configure these
listen and parameters you can go to the
link on the screen and it will take you
to a github gist that will give you a
PowerShell Stearn appear that shows you
how to do that
what about Linux and we were a Google
conference we should talk about Linux at
some point so the good news is that you
can actually run sequel server on Linux
and you've been able to since sequel
Server 2016 if you really wanted to you
could run it in a docker container as
well also since the equals Server 2016
and in fact Windows Server 2016
the main independent availability groups
being a possibility so in Windows Server
2016 Microsoft introduced the domain
independent cluster previously all the
members of a cluster had to be part of
the same domain but in Windows Server
2016 that limitation was removed and
members of a cluster could be from
different domains different forests or
even just workgroup joined the domain
independent availability group was
introduced in sequel Server 2016 just as
a way of creating availability groups on
top of those domain independent clusters
now this was brought along to sequel
server on Linux in sequel server 2017
and you're actually able to create
availability groups on top of pacemaker
clusters you may also be wondering if
you can mix Windows and Linux servers
within the same availability group and
the answer is that you sort of can the
issue with it is that you don't get any
sort of high availability and that's
just because there's no common cluster
manager to mediate the fell over of the
IP address if you go to the link on the
screen there's a lot more detail about
how you would set this up on Linux now
you may be wondering about backups it's
quite an important topic and it's not
really one that I'm going to go into a
huge amount of detail today mainly
because it's probably a session in so
I'm right and will give you a couple of
options that you could look at though
the first is creating some sequel jobs
on each of the instances within your
cluster putting some logic in that job
to ensure it only runs on a single
instance at a time potentially just by
seeing if that instance is the currently
active one for the availability group
and then having a stay within a sequel
job to offload that backup on to cloud
storage there are also a number of
third-party products that you can use
that will be able to back up these
databases to cloud storage so I've gone
about half an hour and I'm a reliability
engineer and this is the first time I've
talked about monitoring again I'm not
going to go into lots of detail about
monitoring mainly because this is
probably
an entire conference in its own right
however I will say that the star driver
monitoring agent can be installed on
Windows and when it is installed on
Windows it's able to gather sequel
server metrics the stat driver logging
agent can also be installed on Windows
and by default that will collect only
the Windows Event log sequel server does
look some things for the event log so
you may be able to just get away with
looking nice but you can also configure
to that driver logging to ingest
text-based logs which sequel server also
keeps so Star Driver logging would be a
good option for any sort of log
management
finally if endpoint health is something
you want to monitor star driver
monitoring does actually give you the
option of using uptime checks so you
could see if that would suit your
purpose so finally for this section
let's just go over some considerations
for always-on in TCP each sequel server
compute engine instance requires its own
subnet the file share witness should be
in a zone in a single region deployment
or a region in a multi region deployment
that has no sequel instances in it
Active Directory isn't actually a
requirement anymore but I still highly
recommend that you include it it's
mainly because it makes management a lot
easier and if you've ever tried setting
up certificate authentication for sequel
server you'll probably wish you had
Active Directory to use instead
synchronous replication should be used
for instances that are in the same
region and conversely asynchronous
replication should be used for instances
though in different regions so now let's
move on to a quick demo just so you can
see what this looks like
quick demo there we go so this is a GCP
console you can see that there are a
number of instances here I have two
domain controllers a file share witness
and two sequel instances all of these
instances are in the same network and
you can see that the two domain
controllers and the file share witness
are all in the same subnet the two
sequel instances are in different
subnets as you can see here I take a
look at sequel warm you can see that it
has an alias IP range configured and
that alias IP range falls within the
range of the subnet that this instance
is in if I switch over to sequel 1 and
reconnect a sequel 1 this is what fell
over customizer would look like you can
see that the core cluster resources are
currently running on sequel warm and if
I scroll down you can see that there is
a resource for the file share witness as
well as they resource for the DNS name
for the core cluster resources and if I
expand that you can see that the IP
address that's online is the one from
the same subnet as sequel warm I switch
to the roles that are running within
this cluster I have two availability
groups 81 is currently running on sequel
1 and 82 is currently running on sequel
to if I look at the resources within 81
you can see that there's a resource for
the availability group there's also a
resource for the listener and a I expand
the listener you can see that the IP
address that's online is in the same
subnet as sequel warm now look at the
same thing for 82 you'll see the same
resources the only difference here is
that the IP address that's online is in
sequel to subnet so if I switch over to
measuring studio you can see here that
sequel Warren has 4 databases on it all
four databases are in the synchronize
State
and sequel to has the same four
databases again all in the synchronized
state I take a look at the availability
groups on sequel one you'll see that
sequel warned is primary for 81 and
secondary for a g2 I take a look at
sequel - you'll see it's the other way
round so let's take a look at the
properties of one of these availability
groups you can see that a g1 has two
databases in it DB 1 + DB 2 it also has
two instances as a member of the
availability group those instances are
both using the synchronous commit
availability mode and I can actually
easily change those through asynchronous
if I want to just by selecting it here
they're also set to use the automatic
failover mode that just means that if
one of these instances fails the other
can automatically pick up from it I can
change that to manual if I would like to
and in fact if I'm using the
asynchronous commit mode the manual is
my only option you can also see that the
instances are set to be readable
secondaries if I take a look at the
read-only reading list you can see that
there are two instances they each have
their own read-only routing URL which
tells the client where to connect to and
then they have their own individual
read-only routing list so now let's try
doing a failover and see what happens so
I actually have an app running here it's
very simple all it's doing is every five
seconds it's connecting to each of the
listeners running these select attached
server name sequel statement and just
returning the value of that command so
that will tell us which instance is
currently active it will also give us
the count of the errors that are found
when attempting the connection so if we
initiate a failover of a g1 all I need
to do is to step through the wizard
select which instance to fail over to
you can see in this case there's going
to be no data loss because they're using
synchronous commit mode
connect to the instance that I'm going
to build over tea and then wait a few
seconds for the fell over to complete
there you go the fell over is complete
you can see the sequel one is now
secondary for a GU one sequel to is
primary for a g1 and if I goes to fell
over cluster manager you can see that
the owner node is now sequel to and the
IP address that's online is the one in
sequel to subnet I go over to the app
you can see that the active instance is
now sequel to and there was actually an
error during that fold over let's try
the same thing with a g2 so again we
initiate the fold over and step through
the wizard wait a few seconds for the
wizard to complete and there we go a g2
is failed over again 82 is now primary
on sequel 1 and if we refresh this equal
to we'll see that a g2 is now secondary
on there again we go to Pearl over
cluster manager take a G to the owner
node is equal 1 and the IP address
that's online is in sequel and subnet we
go back over to the app you can see that
sequel 1 is now the active instance 482
and there were no rare errors during
that fell over now it's worth pointing
out here that actually it's normal to
get a connection failure when the fell
over is completed and that's usually
during the point at which the IP address
has moved from one instance to another
or in this case the IP address changes
what you should do in your app is to
have some kind of logic in there too we
attend the connection and you'll
probably find that on the second attempt
it will probably be successful so use
something like an exponential back-off
for it so that's it for the demo if we
go back to the slides I did have a video
here just in case the demo gods didn't
smile on me but thankfully that works I
can skip over that
if you go to the link on the screen you
will find some step-by-step instructions
for how to set this up in GCP there'll
be some g-cloud command so be sure some
powershell snippets and it should
hopefully give you enough information to
get this up and running yourself I'll
let you all take a picture and all its
that for me Fay is thank you for coming
along I hope you found this useful hope
you got some useful information from
here
[Music]